c'est la première fois qu'il manque un
prime sur tf1 mais ce qui nous a
vraiment manqué c'est la question que je
me posais parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens sur les réseaux bonjour fou je mets
à nikos a
ajouté que j'avais regardé une de ses
émissions jugement car le cul
ne déroge pas voilà tu sais pas j'ai pas
juninho
je vais bien je m'en fous mais je
regarde ces démissions 50 minutes inside
the man car le cul the voice je vais
m'en tape total
mais moi je connais pas je connais comme
ça j'aime bien fait la paix voilà y'a
quoi d'autre qui fait soir un bateau là
il fait des trucs sur un bateau les
faits je regarde un
truc avec des gens là des artistes n'est
pas de mise sur la tête de ma mère que
comme en
fin de l'année passée péniblement daniel
[Rires]
fumée qui présentait avec beaucoup de
gens sur les régions qui ont dit que lé
bas l'été est là il est super bien et
que voilà que pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
pourquoi le remplacerait pas et donc
voilà vous savez j'aime beaucoup
alessandra sublet après je vous dire moi
c'est pas mon problème tout ça à chacun
de nous
passionner
milhas a fait le sujet
elle est super rayonnante si rayonnant
avec pc qui sait pas mais à 13
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai pas lu alors les honneurs c'est
un peu compliqué mais ce cas là mais
l'euro millions qui n'a pas du tout
marché des reçus renverra sur la fin sur
le redoux une énorme fumisterie
alors trop vision là je fais engueuler
et alors là c'est ça c'est en fin
d'émission je fais défoncer l'eurovision
c'est honteux ce qui s'est passé moi
hanouna moi qui suis un défenseur de
l'eurovision qui l'animé deux fois alors
un vrai deux fois 1 g traîner mes
guêtres là-bas en russie et au à norvège
soit les pendant la nuit mais
l'eurovision et j'en ai chié l'est
bulgarie un jour la grèce à tout à
l'heure c'est l'eurovision banque parle
et je peux vous dire qu'ils vont avoir
affaire à moi ça dure longtemps leur vie
dans la maison mais on va reparler
auquel il sauva sublet remplacer
microsoft
mais vous l'aimez bien nico j'ai rien
contre les coups s'il a regardé
l'émission les jumeaux car le cul
non mais moi je regarde le people j'ai
rien à [ __ ] 50 minutes inside
franchement je m'en tape comme je m'en
fous si pour regarder les reportages
d'un mec sur un bateau franchement il
estime d'ailleurs c'est une pub
clandestine d'incroyables a recommandé
précis intéressés sur 50 minutes inside
ils finissent toujours par montrer un
endroit de rêve où tout est super bon
les discours sont toujours les mêmes il
ya les stars arrive ça va coincer
budgétaire est une star je suis jamais
allé dans les endroits qu'ils ont dit
c'est des choses changent marchandises
donne pas les noms mais ce que je suis
avec daniel tous les sens et pour ce
soir sur la marchandise après l'émission
est en fait déjà nettement vejen
bébé
est à côté d'un jockey
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes en direct sur tf1 pour la
demi finale
pas échappé nico serait pas là ce soir
je tiens à t'embrasser très fort et au
nom de tous à te souhaiter un bon
rétablissement
je t'aime à la semaine prochaine comme
ça va je vous avoue que j'ai un peu le
trac
merci beaucoup c'est remettre plus plus
vous arrivez plus vous avez ce petit
côté coquin simona quel finaliste vous
avez choisi pour marc lavoine nous
allons savoir maintenant
c'est caroline costa
c'est parti attention
[Musique]
petite question juste gagner parce que
j'ai des coups c'est caroline que ça qui
est en finale elle devait pas lent
croisière
[Applaudissements]
m
à
[Applaudissements]
c'était ça c'était baba c'est tout pour
moi
pour cette blague de fouet
as tu verras beinheim oui mais bon
qu'est ce qu'on en dit deux mots
qu'elle s'en est très bien s'en était
prévenu à la dernière minute même le ça
fait du bien de voir une femme en prime
sur tf1 la présentation parce que depuis
les départs de laurence boccolini et
course où il ya peu de farine des co
animatrice et ça montre quelque chose de
terrible télé malheureusement pour nikos
et qui n'a pas coupé imprègne depuis
2001 depuis la star ac là il le loupe
une fois on voit que ça change pas grand
chose à l'émission l'audience elle est
sensiblement la même donc en télé nul
n'est irremplaçable et on est tous assez
j'écris
bon vent de fraîcheur elle a été doué
mais ça montre aussi que dans ses
émissions le présentateur n'a aucun
intérêt aucune importance vous pouvez
interchanger au dernier moment
c'est comme à l'époque de secret story
tout ça a
marché mais mieux sans lui
pour respecter castaldi oui non mais
attends pas d'âme
vraiment c'est là où on voit l'emportant
6 présentateur parce que moi j'ai trouvé
que ce coup ci avait de la fraîcheur il
y avait de l'énergie ce qu'on n'a pas
d'habitude donc moi j'ai trouvé ça
exceptionnel qu'elle soit là il faut
qu'elle reste tout le temps elle a
exterminé médecin
passa les abatteuses est sympa mais nous
la norme moi j -p non évidemment elle
est belle elle est dynamique elle et
elle est souriante elle a un côté en
plus bonne camarade moi j'aurais été
formidable en ce moment parce qu'elle
est bien parce qu'elle est détaché parce
qu'elle veut plus faire ça à oissel veut
être actrice et donc du coup il n'y a
pas d'objectif c'est comme yatma parier
sur une meuf agacement et ben c'est là
que vous y regardez là niait les bas de
bassenge me rien quand tu sois difficile
mais si on n'aime rien ne déteste pas
trop quand même
vous avez des pompes tu veux dire quoi
moi rien
demandé cassoulet oui non ton avis mais
j'ai dit elle est rayonnante et les
magnifiques moi je suis content de
l'avoir moi c'est une émission que
j'aime bien mais c'est vrai que le
concept est plus fort que l'animateur
évidemment de johnny dessus là
l'émission n'oublions pas que comme
comme effectivement ça fait des années
qu'il n'a rien loupé tout d'un coup
quand il n'est pas là on a le sentiment
qu'il se passe quelque chose
d'incroyablement ouais c'est normal quoi
qui quoi qu'il se passe on se dit ah bah
tiens c'est différent ça fait du bien ça
change mais quand il va revenir on va
tourner tout le monde va dire quand même
il était le tonnage en soutien à ben
ouais on se fait chier banon